many of you know master p is a hip-hop
icon he is certainly that after a song
make him say atop the charts he went on
to build an empire investing in
everything from fashion to real estate
and spreading a message of racial equity
through financial empowerment that was
his thing still is this thing but today
the father of nine is speaking in his
very first tv interview about a very
family tragedy hits very close to home
the loss of his daughter tatiana miller
she was 29 she'd been battling substance
abuse for nearly a decade and she openly
discussed her struggle with addiction on
the reality series growing up hip-hop
where master p and his son romeo miller
encouraged tatiana to get help in may
though tatiana lost her battle with
addiction and died by accidental
overdose master p is now turning this
heartbreaking loss into a mission and he
joins us now here on cbs mornings i'm so
glad to see you i'm so sorry it's under
these circumstances because it's not the
natural order of things for parents to
outlive their children yeah um
it's hard it's very hard uh coming from
where i come from coming from poverty
you would think that you would outlive
your kids and that was the mission yeah
and i feel like going to my daughter's
funeral i feel like i went to my own
film and i mm-hmm i don't even want to
go to no more funerals
oh how were you notified percy that she
had oh my other daughter called me it
was it was the worst call
that a parent can get
and knowing that you are successful
and
you know my sympathy go out
to uh
to everybody that lost the child
uh when you look at this
and and i said i'm gonna turn my
pain into passion
uh and i'm gonna turn it in to a purpose
because i can't get my daughter back
yeah i love her i think about her every
day and
it took me and my family
to to go through something that
i can't like i just can't stop thinking
about but i realized that i have to get
out here and help and say but the kids
so but but did you think she was getting
better because you know she had talked
very openly about it you as a family had
talked very openly about getting her
help on the show did you think she was
getting better yeah no she was getting
better we had just got out of rehab
and she was on the right chart track
and uh the sad thing about it i know
that you know my daughter said
uh
you know i want to be the president i
want like you know she was getting
herself like i want to do something to
help people and that's why i said you
know my daughter has been my parachute
and i and she was writing a book i said
we have to
uh
get rid of the negative things and
replace it with positive things
when you look back on it do you think
that there are things that you should
have done not have done things you
should have said that you didn't said
are you playing that tape in your head
well no every parent do that yeah i feel
like i could have done more uh i feel
like but you never know like you think
we've been going through this for nine
years so you think oh you know what
she's going to get past this we're going
to go on and live happily ever she's an
adult and she's an adult uh it's been
plenty of times to where
i was in situations that i had to
even if the police was involved like she
could go where she wants she's over 18.
so i had to deal with that struggle and
pain
but
my daughter had a lot of life left in
her yeah and uh she was a happy
uh woman
that that knew that tomorrow she could
do something better so you know and when
something like this happens it it
affects the whole family yes what did
what did you do as a family to get
through this what have you been doing
what are you saying well my thing is is
anybody that's watching this uh
love your loved ones while they're here
because once you walk out that door you
never know who's gonna come back did you
speak to your own family about it yeah
i did a i did a family meeting then
after her death yes and what'd you say
in the family meeting well you know i
mean i asked my kids i say what am i
doing wrong
and so
you know some of the kids say you are
controlling
so i had to look at my own mirror and
said
you know
that's true but i've only built
parameters for protection
out of love because i know where i come
from and what i've been through and we
look at mental illness and substance
abuse it's serious it affects everybody
black white asian latino rich poor
oh you look at now fentanyl just a
little
thing of fentanyl it's destroying take
your life take it like i watched on the
news today to where uh a mother was
talking about her son was a good kid and
he just went left one time and brought
some pill and it killed him so
my thing is
it hurts so much as a family like we go
so for me i broke so many stereotypes
and i'm telling my kids i told my son
romeo i said you know what i broke
a whole lot of
stereo
types and and curses
that
now you got to break cuz he's my hero
romeo is my hero romeo is yeah yeah
because i feel like now he could
change the next generation because you
worked so hard to make sure that they
didn't have the life that you had isn't
that the point you're getting yeah and
it's tough because when you lose
somebody
uh they're not coming back so when i got
that phone call i realized that
my daughter is never coming back yeah
and and that's the heartbreaking thing
about this
and that's why i said
let me team up with with naomi let me
team up with
cares uh these these are doctors these
are people that believe we i want to
help people that look like us we want to
uh bring awareness to this we want to
save these like my whole purpose is now
is i don't know why you put me through
this guard and and i'm not gonna
question you but i'm gonna get out here
and save millions i'm gonna i'm gonna
help i'm gonna do something so your
bottom line message to people who are
worried about their own children or who
are going through this is to do what
you know what um
talk about it yeah don't hold this as
you're afraid to talk about it stop like
because when you talk about mental
illness and you talk about substance
abuse people don't want to say this
happened to my kid but this is affecting
us as americans uh if this is affecting
people international
uh don't be afraid and and and i'm even
telling companies all across the world
like stop holdings as a secret because
you know even me starting to bring
soldier snacks i said you know what
it's so many mental illness when you
deal with soldiers going out there
fighting for us for our country but who
talks to these people who comfort them
you know even like my daughter when
she's going through something on her
friends because we just dealt with
several of her friends losing their
lives and we never thought this would
hit our house well some nobody ever does
but people are looking at you today
saying if it can happen to you all that
you have it can happen to anybody and
you want people to know this can be
avoided but we do have to speak about it
we thank you thank you for coming today
thank you i'm so sorry this has happened
to you and your family